but let's uh let's jump into the first
story about fox
uh i'm sorry the biden administration
working with it's from fox business the
bite administration working with
industry
to develop covet 19 passports as
vaccinations
progress passports offer a glimpse of a
future that
many are longing for after months of
covet 19 restrictions i really love that
fox is saying that
people are longing for vaccine passports
aren't aren't you guys because
kanji ian don't you want to be able to
have an app where they can know
everything about you and you scan it if
you want to go shopping
i'm really bummed that it's an app and
not paper makes things a lot more
difficult show me your papers
no they're saying it's it it will also
be paper oh okay
i think coveted passports okay hold on
this is like the social credit score in
china
right well so they implemented a similar
system i'll just break it down very
simply for for those that don't know
what it is
you will have an app on your phone you
will put in all your private information
and then when you get vaccinated it will
have that information if you go to the
store or you go to a theater or you go
to an airline
they'll have an app like you must scan
it to prove you've gotten your
vaccinations
i think covet is just the beginning how
long until they're like
oh if you want to go to the store have
you gotten you know your hep shot or
something like that or your tetanus shot
have you gotten your flu shot well you
got to have that and with the ease of an
app like this the vaccine passport
they're calling it
then you know walmart or whoever else
can be like you know what everybody
should get flu shots
end of story so you better carry around
your papers right yeah i don't i don't
have a phone i don't carry paperwork
around with me get off my back
i'm just wondering how long it's going
to take for a black market for
for them to spring up on it you know
fake id dude
yeah i feel like people are going to
have hacked apps like you're going to
people are just going to jailbreak their
phones and make their own apps
medical tracking is terrifying i mean if
they make it so you can't do anything
without it people are going to find a
way to get it
even if they don't actually want to get
the vaccine or if they can't
think about how crazy that's going to be
though like you can't go to walmart
unless you have an app you can scan on
the way in
so what about somebody who doesn't own a
phone right let's say you're really
really poor
you can't even get any kind of
smartphone even though there's some
pretty cheap ones you can't get it
and then where you gotta go you gotta go
to a place to issue a vaccine passport
from a certain place on a card they say
that voter id is racist because
poor people and minorities struggle to
go to the dmv and i'm like dude the dmv
has been around for literally ever
everybody can ask someone yo where's the
dmv at if you if you if you went outside
right now and walked up to a random
person and said hey where can i get a
vaccine they're like i don't know
so you think poor people and these
people you believe are underprivileged
are gonna have an easy time
figuring out how to navigate the system
now they're creating some kind of like
caste system this is like when polio the
vaccine came people wanted that vaccine
because polio's crippling people was
terrifying as deadly it was devastating
so people wanted it you didn't have to
force them to get it and and track to
make sure they got it like
people were just getting it because they
needed it they wanted it this vaccine
this thing has a 99.97
percent recovery rate this this covet
thing
i don't think a vaccine is necessary
especially ones that are accessing blood
clots for older people
maybe for older people yeah maybe but
it's still so early in the process that
that
they rushed it out in like a uh six
months this vaccine's been out
i'm not i'm not super opposed to the
rushing process
i'm i'm concerned about the non-approval
process you know what i mean
as well yeah so the fda hasn't approved
this yet yeah both of those things
concern me
i think that the rush is is scary i mean
we don't know what the lasting effects
of any of this stuff will be we don't
even know what the lasting effects of
covid will be
so just all of it the rush
the lack of you know testing and
approval i
i just it freaks me out and i'm i'm very
pro vaccines i'm not like
anti-facts at all i just think that
people are rushing into this stuff yes
but i was reading about the approval
process from the fda
did you know it's something like it's
something like six months to get to get
legitimate hard fda approval yeah so
it's probably
going to be approved soon so that's why
a lot of people are like well it's an
emergency
authorization i think that matters
because they now you've got canada
talking about blood clots or whatever
it definitely matters but i'd like to
see
fda approval you know what i mean like i
don't think that's unreasonable for me
to be like yo
you know i don't think it's fair new
york's already rolling out the passports
here's the bigger problem it's not the
government doing it
biden's got a plan biden's working with
industry
but they can't force anybody to do
anything what's going to happen is
you're not going to be able to board a
plane you're not going to be able to buy
a ticket from ticketmaster or whatever
they're going to it's going to be social
enforcement in the private sector that's
going to make all this happen like masks
for instance
what happened in texas when they were
like yo we're done with this there was
like some some chain of grocery stores
or something that said nope you still
got to do it
i think walmart was like nope you still
gotta wear masks their um infection
rates are going way down
though right now yep yeah so everything
is just crazy it's like
i don't know i live in the woods up on a
mountain
i interact with like four people a week
like i i'm just like i don't really feel
like i need anything like this
like we're fine we're up in the mountain
you guys can do your things in the city
but but yeah so what about in cities
though what if they said vaccine
passports only in
the city and not in the mountains i mean
i i don't care
i am not i don't want to go to cities i
hate going to cities so i'll stay up on
the mountain you guys can get your
papers down there when did you do you
used to live in big cities
yeah i hate them i like what happened so
i haven't been back to a city since i
moved
to west virginia or i hadn't until last
week because i had to take my cat to an
emergency
vet and it was the whole thing but he
had to go get surgery in richmond
and i went there and i was like wow this
is like the walking dead or something
like this like apocalyptic yeah it was
just everybody's walking around
masks they're all like i don't know it's
just really weird because i hadn't
for the past almost a year i've been up
you know in the mountain you know where
where i am pretty isolated like we go to
the country store
nobody wears a mask we try to buy a
bunch of right wing nut jobs
yeah i love my right wing nut job
community
but uh yeah everything's like normal
like you have to wear a mask if you go
to like the big chain stores
like if you go to walmart or something
but if you go to like the local nursery
or the country store
you're not going to see people wearing
masks and they're going to get looked at
funny if you
if they do take them off yeah they're
like you should take that mask off
yeah and i'm like well it's your
business you know what i mean like
that's that's interesting thing about
the whole mask thing like what if a
business tells you you can't wear masks
and people are like well it's like my my
view is the private business man if
if it's that's the challenge with a lot
of this passport stuff is that it's
social enforcement
yeah if every business is saying we all
do this then what do you do
yeah i guess you just get your passport
right
that's what makes me think this bad
information is freaky like
flu numbers are down covered numbers are
up is that right like their
the flu numbers were way down but those
covered numbers were way up
and they were like oh equal amounts of
deaths is normal but this time it's no
flu deaths it's all coveted deaths
yeah but that could be spurious
correlation maybe
like could be that's the thing they
don't know but they want to force a
vaccine it's crazy
but i'll say this so one of the things
that they've been saying for a long time
is that putting people locking people
inside their homes is a mistake because
kovac transmits easier easier indoors
so it could be that putting people in
their house makes flu go down but then
spreads cove it easier so it was like
the dumbest thing they could have done
but not you know yeah i think that's
like a simple solution i suppose
but when you have in europe they were
like if you're pregnant don't get it if
you have food allergies don't get it
then i'm like okay i won't you know what
i mean i'll chill i'm not in a rush i
think
something like 50 of people said they're
willing to just wait and take it easy
that's what's really interesting when
fox runs a story and they're like
everyone's
longing for this you know reopening i'm
like most people said they're willing to
wait on the vaccine because their
concerns about
you know potential long-term effects
that haven't been studied properly
yeah i might be in like a weird
right-wing bubble because like my
community are all
you know normal sane people who are not
freaking out about anything
and but i'm i'm perfectly happy not
getting a passport
staying on my mountain my garden
ordering
yeah i think everything gets delivered
to my house i don't even go grocery
shopping so it's like
okay you guys enjoy your passport
living in the mountains so here's the
crazy thing though virginia's red
i mean i'm sorry west virginia is red
and virginia's blue like like even right
where west virginia and virginia kind of
meet
it's crazy how i've i've gone out there
and talked to people
and they're liberals well no the border
of west virginia and virginia
they're very red like you drive that
area it's all farmland and you're gonna
see like trump signs everywhere and i
feel really bad for them actually
because it's like they don't get
a vote west virginia actually um i think
it was about a year ago
offered to take those counties into west
virginia yeah
yeah yeah yeah because it sucks for them
like they're all pro-gun they're
you know right-wing and they're being
represented by the people who
work in dc and live in the cities that
are close to dc
and you know why they don't want to live
in dc because it's horrible because
they're racist
no yeah i think i think i absolutely
think it's because most of these
well-to-do progressive liberal types are
super racist
they don't want to live in the cities
that they've destroyed with their
policies
like dc is has a very very high uh
percentage of
black residents it's no surprise that
the people who live
who work in dc and run dc decide to move
out of dc
they don't want to they this is what
happens and now virginia's turning blue
across the board and then they're not
going to want to live there in a year or
two
and they're going to move to maryland or
they're going to move south and go you
know to north carolina or something
and slowly keep moving away from the
things they keep voting for
one of the funny things about west
virginia is i see these stories
where i was talking to a guy at a gun
shop and he was like
you can tell who the liberals are like
when they're moving in because they
complain about mountain things
that no one like no conservative cares
about yeah so like
you know someone said my neighbor left
their trash out and i
why are they doing this you know what do
i got to do to make them pick their
trash in and everyone's like
who cares my local community uh facebook
group is always like joking about that
whenever somebody new moves in they'll
be like
are you guys allowed to be shooting guns
as close to people's houses
and they're like welcome to the mountain
get ready for the utvs and atvs too
people you'll see some you know people
driving around on rascals with a couple
of ars
[ __ ] flags shout out to the united
states because
first i was in the suburbs grew up then
i went to the cities and lived that
part of my life and now in the mountains
it's like another world
it's another world it's like another
country we got this race car
it's like super nice race car and we've
got these two foot quarter pipes in the
parking lot
and we just bought it and we're kind of
like we can do whatever we want so we
just this thing can go 60 miles an hour
oh my gosh
we launched the thing like 25 feet in
the air it's flipping around and
smashes the ground is bouncing and we're
like probably gonna break it's laughing
but you can do that out here
yeah so that's the crazy thing too like
all the whole time with kovid
i've been saying that since you know
when coveted started we were in the
philadelphia area
that was actually really scary you know
you're surrounded by all these people
and then you get told like donald trump
appears on tv and he's like i'm shutting
down travel to europe and all the stuff
and we were like damn this is serious
and we were worried too because like
the supply shortage the toilet paper was
gone like our local walmart toilet paper
all gone
the neighbor bounced like the one name
yeah the neighbor was gone for like two
months and then when the storm blew like
the fence off it was just
just down they just abandoned their
house yeah like too much they took off i
think it was longer than that probably
it's freaky it was like a freaking
summer so then we ended up moving out to
the middle of nowhere
it's like paradise people just go about
their business like normal
you go down to like the local shop
nobody nobody hassles you
i just want to say though we also have
bigfoot people play their banjos really
loud all night
there's a lot of shooting like things in
their front yards
um confederate flags everywhere leftists
don't move don't move out don't move to
west virginia
you will hate it it's awful um and that
is all just had to throw that in so
that's so i tweeted
i tweeted uh i don't know if you saw the
story like lindsey graham said he has an
ar-15
you see that he's like doing an
interview and he's like i got an ar-15
and
you know if it's afraid what he said if
like it goes if it all goes
bad or whatever the gangs this is the
last place the gangs will go because i
can defend myself
and so i tweeted lindsay has an ar15
pathetic
we should ban ar-15s outright completely
and then the government should issue
everyone a barrett m82
50 50 bmg semi-automatic anti-material
rifle
then you'll truly i'm kidding by the way
but you know that's that's the thing
about
west virginia is that well
so i've been buying a lot of bullets
because you know first of all they're
hard to get
and then people were saying you know you
want to have what a thousand rounds per
gun
is like a good amount to have to have on
store and people got to realize this too
i'm sure to people who don't know
anything about guns a thousand rounds
sounds like a lot because it did to me
when i was first buying guns
you go to the range one time and you're
like oh i get it now yeah go through
like 120 really quick or something real
quick i mean if you're with your friends
and you're practicing you're doing
training
you're going to go through you know a
decent amount of rounds quickly so a
thousand rounds might
you know be a couple months of
practicing at the range
if you want to take it seriously a lot
of people don't shoot that much
but for hunting people might shoot a
couple times well so i started buying
bullets and i was like i was talking to
a guy at the shop
and i was like i'm getting a bunch of
12-gauge uh and i was like is this is
this too much just like
does this notify anybody he started
laughing and he goes like
you think you're anywhere close to prep
territory or even west virginia resident
territory
he's like come on man those are rookie
numbers you got to pump those numbers up
i'm like
all right i'll take what you got put
them in the box and then i got like a
huge box of 12 gauge i guess
but it does go quick you know but anyway
i digress we're talking about covid
sorry i'm a west virginia fan girl
apologies
and i like ammo yeah i'm talking about
ammo oh we're going to say
no sorry like i brought this up before
you play fallout
you know caps bottle caps is the
currency of the future after
the nuclear war i think that ammo it
would just be ammo so like you use your
ammo or you trade your ammo the ammo has
weight i think that would be a great
model super valuable yeah like insanely
bad another game i'm playing it's water
is the currency so you carry that around
trade fresh water
yeah but you but it it depends i suppose
fresh water is probably
but you're not going to be carrying on
lots of water it's heavy that's the
problem right cigarettes and whiskey too
so you can get fine like metal copper
and stuff but ammo
cigarettes is a good one yeah
antibiotics
yes bitcoin because people will still
have phones
no yeah i don't know stuff that
disappears after you use it it's hard to
know actually because water makes sense
but you can't carry a lot of water
around with you
you can carry enough for personal use
you carry too much and then you can't
you're actually exerting water to carry
the water it's a great currency
model for a video game because of the
weight plus if you're carrying a big
thing of water on like a wagon
like you're you're targeting a target
yeah these roving bands are going to
show up you have to hide it somehow
so maybe not water but bolts make sense
you know that's for sure also heavy
but i can't imagine that maybe casings
because bullets you got to use
you don't want to give those up they're
too valuable too valuable dude the
apocalypse happens
and you've got just like five nine
millimeter for your gun you're gonna be
like
i will never give these things up you
know i would never want to fire them
that's why i train with the bow and
arrow
because i don't want to waste my hands
though yeah thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show
come back to this channel
youtube.comcast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you